-It's always
so great to see you.
Congratulations on
the return of "Roseanne."
-Thank you very much.
-This must be beyond
your wildest dreams.
Even the fact that it came
together in the first place.
-It was a gift.
And I'm treating it as such.
I'm very grateful
to be back there,
as opposed to last time,
when I was "rehearsing" and...
It was remarkable
how it came together.
I was on Sara Gilbert's
talk show, "The Talk."
-Yes.
-In case there's any confusion.
And we did a little
"Roseanne"-ish sketch
at the top of it.
And during the show, she asked
me if I would be interested
in a reunion show
or something like that.
A clip show. I don't know.
I said, yeah, in a heartbeat.
And she called Roseanne,
said I was interested.
And three weeks later,
we had a deal with
the American
Broadcasting Company...
-That's crazy.
-...also known as ABC.
-You've always been a formal --
You always speak about networks
very formally.
-The DuMont Network.
-[ Laughs ]
It's funny. Obviously you and
Roseanne have this chemistry.
It's incredibly well-honed.
I remember this year
at the Golden Globes
you guys came out
and presented together.
And I was rehearsing
earlier in the day.
And for people who don't know,
they just have extras
do the lines.
So, I was watching, and it was
like a three-line exchange
between you and Roseanne.
But I watched two extras do it,
and I was like,
"This isn't funny at all."
And then you and Roseanne
came out
and said the exact same thing,
and it just crushed.
-Well, they gave me a punch line
that didn't work.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, yeah?
-And she saved my bacon.
-Oh, well, that's --
I think that when you have
a partner in comedy like that,
there's a lot of bacon saving.
-Oh, thank you.
-And you brought back
the whole cast.
You even brought back
both Beckys.
Was that a fun thing to have to
figure out the math of that?
-Yeah, it was amazing. Yeah,
I couldn't recognize them apart.
Which one is which?
Yeah, they fit her in.
She may even be coming back,
I don't know, doing something.
But it's just so bizarre
to walk onto that set
for the first time.
Everything is reproduced
exactly.
And I got chills.
It's not déjàà vu,
but it's something spookier.
I think Laurie Metcalf
calls it a wormhole.
-A wormhole. That makes sense.
So, you said reproduced.
It's not the original set?
-No.
They had to get stuff off of
eBay, I believe, that was ours.
-Oh, really?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The rumor
that I've been spreading
is that the Smithsonian
Institution owns the couch
and they wouldn't
rent it back to us cheaply.
-Right.
-But that's not true.
-It's a good rumor.
-Print the legend.
Yeah, absolutely.
Print the legend.
-Cheap bastards.
I want to tell you
about the government!
Let me tell you about the
government! Aw, they're bad!
-Well, the show, of course, is
a lot now about the government,
not as much as I feel like
it's maybe getting ink for.
Roseanne is a Trump supporter.
Laurie is a Hillary --
a left-wing supporter.
Did you know
going into the season
what the stories
were going to be about?
-I didn't care.
-Yeah, that --
-Which is pretty much
the way I went through
the last nine years of the show.
-Well.
-I don't care!
-The other thing
that I think that helps
is Dan doesn't seem to care.
-No.
-It's basically -- he's along
for the ride, as well.
-He's out in the garage
drinking quite a bit of beer.
-Yeah.
But he looks very svelte.
-Thank you.
-New Dan looks very svelte.
You've done him a great favor.
-Light beer.
-Yeah.